I team listen up this crew is about
family but the game has changed now
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on him so easy
you've only got one chance to make this
family whole again don't do this done
already one thing I can guarantee no
one's ready for this she's the very
definition of itec terrorism there's
thousands of cars in this city and now
they're all mine now I know what it
feels like to be every cop ever chasing
us
[Music]
Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba our paths have
crossed before dawn you just didn't know
it
I think I need to remind you why you
chose to be here I got no choice
if you gotta catch Dom maybe I need a
little help if you want to tell me why
you just put me in a room with this team
crumpets Eton criminal nothing that
tight t-shirts cutting off the
circulation he'll Brian you should get
me this nice you guys are gonna work
together love to I've been waiting for
this we got a tank
now my baby
[Music]
they just don't give up either you
thought this was gonna be a street fight
is that right now take the wheel
what
mr. crazy alright you get style points
for that one I don't know why you're
doing this but I know one thing you love
me
[Music]